Maddie Ziegler is happy her dance mom
days are behind her
[Music]
the fourteen-year-old looks adorable
gracing the july/august cover of
Seventeen magazine on newsstands
Wednesday in her cover story she chats
normal teenage things like real life and
friends she also opens up about her
skyrocketing career as an actress
fashion designer author vlogger and
dancer after the season Maddie's not
going to be on the team anymore as for
her dance mom beginning Maddie says she
was over the drama calling the show a
really stressful time in her life
the Pittsburgh native who starred on the
lifetime hit for six seasons says she's
thankful for the experience and misses
dancing with the girls she's been such a
great ride together but enough was
enough Maddie says she's happy to have
moved on quote I get to step out and do
my own thing and be myself
et caught up with the rising star at the
Kids Choice Awards in March I feel like
now that I've ranched off from like the
show I feel like things have been more
crazy and more busy which is amazing
[Music]